Mein Name ist Tokkös.
Ich bin zuständig erst in der Säbersee.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bevor wir anfangen, möchte ich Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, Hauptsache ich habe jetzt gleich Hilfe, ja.
Ja, wie heißt sie denn?
Ich heiße Frank Wilms.
Frank Wilms.
Ich stabile Ihren Name, Frank, wie F, R, A, N, K.
Richtig. Genau.
Und Nachname Wilms.
Wie W, I, I, I, I, Da, L, M, S.
Ja, genau, so ist richtig.
Herr Wilms, freut mich.
Wie heißt sie Sie?
Moment, ich bin 41.
41.
Was ist die genaue Gewohnung?
Am 2. 1. 84.
84.
Okay. Wissen Sie aktuell, wie groß Sie sind und wie viel Sie liegen?
Ja, ich bin 1.84 und ich wiege so ungefähr 65 kg.
65 kg? 1,98?
Nein, 4.90 kg.
94 kg und 1.84 groß.
Ja.
Okay. Vielen Dank, Halbims. Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für mich, wer da sind?
Ja.
Sie haben Schmerzen vielleicht?
Ja, ich habe solche Schmerzen. Wissen Sie sie hier so oben in der Brust?
Und das hat vor 2 Stunden angefangen.
Und?
Also, ich habe mich überhaupt nicht angestrengt oder so.
Ich habe gar nichts gemacht.
Ich habe nur einfach hier rum gesessen.
Und ich fühle mich mit einmal so eingeengt.
Und beim Einladen, wenn tut es ganz besonders weh.
Und das strahlt so aus in den linken Arm rein.
Ich habe richtig ein bisschen Panik jetzt.
Mir ist schlecht und ich ...
Mir ist ganz kalt, schweißig.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, mein Herz klopft ganz doll.
Also, mir ist richtig schlecht.
Okay.
Es tut mir sehr leid zu hören, Halbims.
Haben Sie früher ein bisschen werden?
Ja, ich habe das schon, also jetzt in letzter Zeit häufiger mal gehabt.
Wenn ich, wenn ich mich sehr angestrengt habe.
Ja, wenn ich also, was weiß ich, gegen den Windfahrrad gefahren bin.
Oder wenn ich die Treppen hoch gerannt bin, dann hatte ich das schon mal.
Aber jetzt ist es so ganz ohne Anlass eigentlich gekommen.
Ich habe gar nichts gemacht.
Verstehe.
Und wie stark ist der Schmerz nach meiner Schmerz-Kalifornie bis zu?
Wobei ich noch kein Schmerzen,
ich werde es nicht mehr sprechen.
Also, am Anfang war es, würde ich sagen, 6.
Jetzt ist es nicht mehr ganz so schlimm.
Jetzt ist es vielleicht so bei, ja, so 3 bis 4 oder so.
Jetzt 3 bis 4.
Ja.
Ja, haben Sie dagegen etwas angenommen?
Nein, nein, ich bin eigentlich so.
Als ich gemerkt habe, dass das gar nicht besser wird,
habe ich mich schon gleich auf den Weg hierher gemacht.
Okay.
Wie sind Sie hierher gekommen?
Ja, eine Nachbar hat mich hierher gebracht.
Ich habe da geklingelt und habe gesagt,
dass es mir nicht gut geht.
Oder hat er gesagt, ja, ich bringe sie eben hin.
Okay.
Herr Bims, ich muss unsere Gespräche unterbrechen
und muss eine EK-Gesoforte geschrieben werden.
Ja.
Und dann für Sie eine Sauerstoffgaben,
für Sie ein paar Benösezugang anlegen.
Parallel werde ich für Sie bei Ihnen
die Schmerz-Enzymen-Bluet abnehmen.
Für die Schmerz-Enzymen-Bluet abnehmen.
Und ich möchte gerne bei Ihnen ein Schmerzmutter geben.
Aber haben Sie Allergien oder Medikamenteallergen?
Ich wüsste nicht, dass ich gegen irgendwas allergisch bin.
Okay.
Ich gebe Ihnen auch eine Anergetik.
Bitte schön.
Ich möchte über die Schmerzmutter und Sauerstoffgaben.
Okay.
Ich möchte weiter sprechen.
Herr Bims, Sie haben seit zwei Stunden diese Schmerzen.
Aber am Anfang wurde diese Schmerzen 6.
Gerade 4, 3 und 4.
Ja, so würde ich das einsortieren, ja.
Aber Sie haben seit letzter Zeit häufig diese Schmerzen beim Belastung.
Ja, aber da hat es nicht so lange gedauert.
Da war das dann irgendwie nach 20 Minuten oder so, war das dann weg.
Ja, seit wann haben Sie diese Probleme?
Ja, das fing so vor einem Jahr im Sommer an.
Seit einem Jahr?
Wegen dieser Probleme haben Sie Ihren Hausarzt besucht?
Ja, ich gehe da schon hin und wieder mal hin.
Ich gehe da eigentlich, ja, erregt mir nur immer, ich soll nicht rauchen.
Und was weiß ich?
Also ich gehe da nicht so gerne hin.
Okay.
Und beschreiben Sie bitte diese Schmerzen.
Sind die Schmerzen erholt und drücken der Bränen der Schmerzen?
Nein, also einmal drückt es, aber es sticht auch.
Also, puh, ja, es sticht.
Und es gibt mir so dieses Gefühl, als ob mir jemand auf der Brust sitzt.
Oh, jemand, okay.
Das klingt sehr schlecht, ja.
Und Sie haben gesagt, ich strahlen, oder?
Ich habe nicht gehört.
Ja, das geht so bis in den linken Arm hinein, ja.
Linken Arm.
Nur linken Arm, strahlen nur linken Arm?
Oder vielleicht?
Sonst nicht, sonst nimm woanders.
Ja, okay.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie fühlen sich auch übel.
Haben Sie erbrochen?
Am Anfang war mir total schlecht.
Und jetzt ist es ein klein bisschen besser.
Aber ich habe wirklich ein bisschen Angst haben,
deswegen habe ich auch gleich mal Nachbarn gerufen
und habe gesagt, ob er mir helfen kann, ja,
ob er mich herbringt.
Ja, Sie haben gut gemacht.
Und haben Sie erbrochen?
Nein, nein, ich musste mich, Gott sei Dank,
musste ich mich nicht übergeben.
Okay.
Herr Wilms, gab es, was diese Schmerzen,
gab es etwas, was diese Probleme oder Beschwerden auslösen?
Nein, eben nicht.
Das ist ja das, was ich so komisch finde.
Sonst habe ich das schon mal gehabt,
wenn ich mich angestrengt habe,
aber jetzt habe ich gar nichts gemacht.
Das finde ich komisch, ja.
Ja, interessant.
Gab es etwas, was diese Bische werden,
Lindart oder Verstärkt?
Nein, kann ich jetzt nicht sagen,
es ist ja auch noch nicht so lange jetzt.
Also mit der Zeit ist es ein bisschen besser geworden, ja.
Aber früher, wenn Sie ruhen,
ja, was macht man,
dadurch, dass man so ein bisschen diese Panik hat,
ich mache dann meistens das Fenster auf
und versuche, so ein bisschen ruhig zu atmen.
Aber dann ist es auch immer besser geworden, ja.
Frische Luft?
Okay.
Haben Sie Asma Bronschiale?
Bitte, was?
Asma Bronschiale, Asma.
Nein, das habe ich nicht,
aber ich habe so ein bisschen chronischen Husten,
habe ich schon seit langer Zeit, ja.
Chronische Husten.
Rachen Sie vielleicht?
Ja, ja, ja.
Wie viel Zigarette rachen Sie täglich?
Also eigentlich habe ich nie so viel geraucht.
Ich habe immer nur so ein halbes Päckchen,
so zehn Zigaretten am Tag, das war so das Maximum.
Aber in letzter Zeit habe ich schon auch ein bisschen mehr geraucht.
Da habe ich schon auch oft mal ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht, ja.
Ein paar Kumpelsigaretten seit wann?
Bitte?
Ja, sind vielleicht so in den letzten 3, 4 Jahren.
3, 4 Jahren.
Vorher rachen Sie nur ein halber Päckchen Zigaretten.
Ja, ja, ungefähr.
Wie viele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Ja, ich habe früh angefangen, mit 18 habe ich angefangen.
Mit 18 Jahren.
Okay.
Aber es ist so viel, Herr Wins,
haben Sie versucht, um nicht dein Rauch und aufzuhören?
Ach, ich habe so viel Ärger,
da kann ich nicht auch noch mit dem Rauch und aufheben.
Es gibt aber viele Möglichkeiten,
um Stress zu reduzieren.
Wenn Sie Hilfe brauchen, wir sind für Sie da.
Also jetzt brauche ich erstmal Hilfe, weil mir schlecht ist
und weil ich solche Schmerzen habe, ja.
Und fühlen Sie sich gut, nachdem ich mehr Stichmittel und Sauerstoff habe?
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass es jetzt ein bisschen leichter ist, ja.
Okay, super.
Herr Wins, haben Sie Stress in der Arbeit oder im Leben?
Ja, also, ja, doch.
Also bei der Arbeit ist es schon auch stressig.
Da geht es immer um Termine und Termine.
Und ja, ich bin geschieden.
Um eine Tochter lebt bei mir, insofern habe ich schon auch viel um die Ohren, ja.
Okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Speditionskaufmann.
Bitte noch mal.
Okay.
Also geht es immer um Termine und um Auslastung von Fahrzeugen.
Und ja, es ist immer viel zu tun.
Okay, ich lafe Sie gut?
Ja, also, normalerweise doch, ja.
Manchmal trinke ich abends auch dann noch eine Flasche Bier
oder ein Glas Wein, um runterzukommen abends.
Ja, dann kann ich auch ganz gut einschlafen.
Okay, vor dem Schlafen trinken Sie oft Alkohol.
Ja, also immer mal in der Woche, ja.
In der Woche.
Und es ist auch nicht so gut, Herr Beems, für die Gesundheit.
Alle machen das, alle trinken ein bisschen Alkohol.
Ja, ich weiß.
Aber jede Woche trinken Sie auch Alkohol.
Ja, ich trinke immer mal in der Woche.
Ich bin ja sehr stolz.
Ich bin stolz.
Du kannst immer noch ein bisschen Alkohol trinken.
Ich habe mich auch über die Gesundheit.
Alle trinken ein bisschen Alkohol.
Ja, ich weiß.
Aber jede Menge Alkohol ist gefährlich für unsere Köpfe.
Deswegen, bitte denken Sie daran,
Ihren Trinkgewohnheiten nochmal.
Okay.
mit der Scheidung und wenn viel Stress ist bei der Arbeit, dann ist das ist
besonders. Okay, seit wann haben Sie geschieden? Ja, vor vier Jahren. Seit vier
Jahren geschieden. Okay. Und okay, vier Jahre. Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben
Herzrasen und Angst, kalte Gefühle auch während dieser Schmerzen und
Atmen. Ja, als es losging, da ging es mir mit einmal ganz schlecht, ja. Und haben Sie während
diese Atmprobleme und Schmerzen, Husten, Auswurf?
Husten, Auswurf, haben Sie ja Husten und Auswurf?
Ein bisschen, ja, weil ich das eigentlich ständig habe, ja. Husten, ein bisschen. Und wie sagt das Auswurf?
Ja, das ist so sehr schleim, so ein bisschen. Okay, schleim ich, aber wie, welche Farbe?
Ja, eigentlich durchsichtiger schleim. Was meine Sie damit? Verstehen Sie? Ja, so durchsichtig wie
durchsichtig oder? Nicht, nicht geldlich, nein, nein. Okay, weiß ich. Okay, haben Sie Fieber?
Oh, ich habe mich nicht gemessen, aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich Fieber habe.
Gut, sind Sie jetzt seit Grippe oder Erkältung?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Erkältung, gut. Haben Sie nach Schweiß oder Schütterfrost?
Nein, ich hatte jetzt nur diesen Schweißausbruch da eben, als das losgegangen ist.
Okay, während dieser Atmprobleme. Ja, genau.
Und wie ist die Appetit?
Normalerweise ist es sehr gut, jetzt heute ist es natürlich nicht gut, aber also normal.
Ja, ganz normal. Ist Ihnen in der Zeit Gewichtsverlust oder Gewichtszunahme aufgefallen?
Ich wieg mich jetzt nicht ständig, aber ich denke mal, ich wieg immer so das Gleiche.
Gewichtsverlust, gut.
Verstehe, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen Stuhlgang?
Na Gott sei Dank nicht, nee.
Müssen Sie in der Nacht Wasserlassen?
Nein, hören Sie, ich bin 41, da wird das ja hoffentlich mal so gehen.
Ja, Sie sind sehr jung, ja. Und Sie haben keinen Aufstuhlgang-Problem, oder?
Nee, alles ganz normal. Ich bin eigentlich immer gesund, ja.
Außer Ihren Brustbein, gibt es auch die andere Körperteile Schmerzen.
Ich meine Beinschmerzen, oder?
Nee, sonst tut es weh.
Nein, nein, nein, nur hier in der Brust tut es weh.
Ist Ihnen Beinschwillungen aufgefallen?
Nein, also ich bin nicht aufgefallen, aber ich habe auch nicht darauf geachtet, nein.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nee.
Gut.
Herr Wim, Sie sind sehr jung, Sie haben nur chronische Husten.
Ja, genau.
Haben Sie eine feste Diagnose bei Ihnen?
Wurde eine feste Diagnose festgestellt?
Ich meine, Raha-Lunga oder Chronis...
Also mein Arzt hat gesagt chronische Husten,
und wenn ich Probleme habe, nehme ich halt ACC.
ACC, okay. Und hilft das?
Ja, dann geht es mir eigentlich, also dann kann ich das abhusten so ein bisschen, ja.
Mhm, okay. Aber Sie haben keine COPD Diagnose bekommen.
Nein, nein, ich weiß gar nicht, was das ist. Nein, nein, ich habe noch nicht.
Sag ich mal, dass Sie an chronische Husten...
Ja, das fing eigentlich schon ziemlich früh an.
Ja, also mit Anfang 20 fing das schon an.
Seit Mit, okay.
Sonst noch andere chronische Erkrankungen?
Nein, nix, nee, nee.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, ich hatte einmal nach einem Unfall,
der linke Unterschenkel war kompliziert gebrochen
und dann ist operiert worden.
Linke Unterschenkel, oh, ist mit seiner Wand genau?
Ah, das ist jetzt 15 Jahre her.
Die war 15 Jahre?
Nein, es ist 15 Jahre her.
Okay, 15 Jahre. Wie wurde es behandelt?
Operationen?
Ich bin da operiert worden,
weil es so Metall eingesetzt worden ist und nachher wieder anfangen.
Verliebt die Oper gut?
Ja, es war schon lange her,
aber ich kann mich nicht erinnern, dass da irgendwas kompliziert war.
Super.
Und sonst noch andere Oper?
Nein, sonst bin ich noch nie operiert worden.
Okay, nehmen Sie bei Bedarf ATC-Tableten.
Ja, genau.
Außer diese Tableten, nehmen Sie bei Bedarf oder regelmäßig mit Liebdienken?
Nein, ich nehme sonst gar nix.
Super. Sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas?
Nein, haben Sie ja schon gefragt, aber ich bin nicht allergisch.
Sie haben keine Medikamente, aber die andere Polenallergie oder was?
Nein, ich wüsste nicht, dass ich auf irgendwas allergisch reagiere.
Und Unverträglichkeiten?
Vertragen Sie alle Lebensmittel?
Also bisher alles, was ich essen wollte, konnte ich essen, ja.
Super. Und Sie haben gesagt, ich trinke vor dem Schlaf nicht was.
Wie viel Alkohol trinken Sie?
Ja, ich trinke mal eine Flasche Bierabend oder auch mal ein Glas Wein.
Ja, ein Glas Wein.
Oder, und seit wann?
Ja, also, was weiß ich?
Als Jugendlicher habe ich natürlich ein bisschen mehr getrunken.
Da hat man häufiger mal abends ein bisschen gefeiert.
Aber jetzt muss ich ja auch arbeiten und kann mir das gar nicht erlauben,
total K.o. zu sein.
Also, ja, ein, zwei Flaschen Bier am Abend höchstens, ja.
Okay. Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Es ist eine Routinefrage. Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Drogen? Nee, nee, nee, das nehme ich nicht.
Super. Leben Ihre Alten doch, Harwins.
Mein Vater ist ganz früh gestorben.
Der hat sie mit 50 ein Herzinfarkt.
Aber meine Mutter, die lebt noch, die hat...
50 Jahre? War er 50 Jahre alt?
Er war 50 Jahre alt, ne?
Oh, es tut mir so leid.
Meine Mutter, die lebt noch, die hat nur ein bisschen so Rheuma beschwerden.
Sie tun alle Gelenke weh.
Oh, es tut mir so leid. Alle Gelenke.
Und haben Sie Geschwester?
Nee, ich habe keine Geschwester. Ich war einst ihr Kind.
Okay. Sie arbeiten eine Spedition Kaufmann.
Genau.
Eine Spedition Kaufmann seit vier Jahren.
Sind Sie geschieden? Haben Sie feste Lebenspartner?
Nein, nein, nein, ich bin jetzt alleine.
Meine Tochter lebt bei mir, ne?
Ja, mit Ihren Tochter. Okay.
Ihre Tochter ist Ihre Tochter gesund?
Ja, ja, ja, die ist gesund.
Gut.
Sind Sie vorständig gegen Corona?
Ja, da habe ich alle Impfungen, die man seinerzeit so kriegen konnte.
Super. Und zeigen Sie sich sportregelmäßig?
Also, so richtig regelmäßig nicht.
Manchmal fahre ich mit einem Fahrrad halt.
Und ja, im Sommer mache ich auch mal ein bisschen Sport.
Aber ja, also regelmäßig würde ich das jetzt nicht nennen.
Okay. Sind Sie im letzten Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Nee, lange nicht. Nein, nein, in letzter Zeit gar nicht.
Okay, Herr Weems, ich bin fertig. Wünschte Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ich wüsste jetzt nicht. Sie haben ja so viel gefragt.
Und ich habe Ihnen ja auch schon viel erzählt.
Jetzt wüsste ich halt nur gerne, ja,
jetzt haben Sie mir ja schon geholfen mit den Schmerzmitteln.
Geht es mir ja schon ein bisschen besser,
aber was kann man denn auf Dauer gegen die Beschwerden tun?
Herr Weems, ja, ich verstehe Ihre Sorge.
Aber wir haben alles im Unterkontrolle.
Ja, ich habe für Sie einen Verdacht, eine Herzkrankheit.
Deswegen muss ich bei Ihnen einige Untersuchungen durchführen.
Es wäre besser, wenn Sie bei uns behalten.
Wenn ich bei Ihnen bleibe, meinen Sie?
Ja, in Krankenhaus.
Deswegen, ich werde sofort bei Ihnen körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
Dann Herzuntersuchungen.
Herzuntersuchungen bei Coronar.
Herzkatheteruntersuchungen.
Aber ist das nicht gefährlich, sondern Herzkatheteruntersuchungen?
Wir haben ein paar Geferliche.
Aber jede Eingriff hat ein Problem.
Jeder Eingriff hat gefährliche.
Hat ein Risiko.
Jeder Eingriff hat ein Risiko.
Aber ist das denn ein Eingriff, eine Corona-Angiografie?
Das ist nicht eine schwierige Situation.
Wir werden nur eine kleine Düne-Katheter in ihren Gefäßen,
insbesondere ihren leichten Bereich, gefüllen.
Ich denke, Sie wollen das Herz untersuchen. Warum dann die Leiste?
Ich denke, Sie wollen das Herz untersuchen.
Das Herz muss sich in den Arturien, den Sie sich überlegen.
Das Herz muss sich überlegen.
Das Herz ist nicht gefährlich.
Es gibt auch ein paar Entschuldung, Verletzungen oder Bulletungen.
Aber wir sind eine super Team.
Wir haben keine Komplikationen.
Wir gucken.
Gut.
Ja, ich habe sie da jetzt natürlich ein bisschen außer Fassung gebracht.
Ja, mit meinen Nachfragen.
Gut.
Möchte ich jemand noch etwas anderes fragen, außerdem?
Nee, gibt keine weiteren Fragen.
Okay.
Sehr geehrte Frau Oberarztin, ich habe einen neuen Patentin, den ich Ihnen vorstellen
möchte.
Es geht um Herr Frank Wilms.
Er ist 41 Jahre alt.
Wie alt ist er?
41.
Ja, okay.
In beschwerden bedingte reduziertem Allgemeinszustand und die leichte
übergewichteten Ernehmungszustand.
Er ist übergewichtig im Änderungszustand.
Okay.
Herr Wilms starte sich bei uns aufgrund seit zwei Stunden
plus ich bestehende Druckende Stiche
und mit Ausstrahlung in die linkseitige, in den linken Arm.
Das war, als des Weiteren klackte er über kalte Schweiß, kalte Schweiß,
nausea, düsmnö, die Schmerzintensität, die dabei am Anfang 6 von 10,
aber im Laufe der Zeit 3 bis 4 von 10 auf der nimmerischen Schmerzskala.
Er habe früher endische, aber leichte Belastungsabhängige schmerzen.
Er hat, er hat, er hat früher spontan 20 Minuten verloren.
Er hat, er hat, er hat.
Es hat, auch so früher hatte es sich spontan nach 20 Minuten gelegt
oder es war beendet, die Problematik.
Und jetzt ist es halt weiter gewesen.
Ja.
Des Weiteren, okay, oda.
Daruba hinaus, oda, Daruba hinaus,
die Fragen nach Hemoptüse, Beinödeme,
Beinödeme, Nectury wurden verneint.
Die begrehte Tiefe Anamnese ist unauffällig bis auf Insomni seit 4 Jahren.
Ja, als Auslöser, als mögliche Auslöser nannte er Stress bei der Arbeit und im Leben.
Aber ich denke ja.
Okay.
An vor Erkrankung werden die Folgenden bekannt.
Seit, er leide an seit, seit 20, 20, 20 Lebensjahren, 20 Lebensjahren chronische Husten.
Er wurde vor 15 Jahren in Folge eines Fahrerfahrens.
Eines Unfalls, ja?
Link seitige, Bein fragt zu.
Es wurde mit Ostösentese operiert.
Behandelt, ja.
Und es wurde mit der Medikamente an der Neese, Neeme, Ersch, Beinbeder,
ACC Tableten an.
Er sei allergie und, die Fragen nach allergie und Unferklichkeiten,
wurden verneint.
Er trinke seit 3 bis 4 Jahren ein schachtes Zigaretten pro Tag.
Er raucht, er raucht, hau'n wir nicht.
Ja, entschuldigung.
Er rauche seit 3 bis 4 Jahren ein schachtes Zigaretten pro Tag.
Aber zuvor habe er ein halbes schachtes Zigaretten seit 8 Jahren.
Seit dem 18. Jahr?
Seit dem 18. Jahr geraucht.
Das bedeutet übermäßige Nikatinabusus.
Und er trinke ein Fleischer Bier oder Englatsweinabens.
Aber seit Jugendalter habe er mehr getrunken.
Im Jugendalter hat er mehr getrunken.
Im Jugendalter? Ja.
Moment, Entschuldigung.
Geht gerade nicht so gut.
Ich bin im Zoom gerade.
Was ist los?
Er ist jetzt supergefallen.
Bitte was?
Er ist supergefallen.
Ja, natürlich.
Die Familienanahmese ergeben, sein Vater sei an Myokartinfarktis mit 50. Lebensjahr verstorben.
Seine Mutter sei lebt.
Und sie leidet noch?
Ja, sie leidet an Myokartinfarktis und hat eine andere
Annamnestische Angabe am ersten auf, eine akute Coronar-Sendrom hin.
Die differenzieren Diagnostik, die folgenden Inbetracht, die kommunalen, die folgenden Inbetracht.
Wie ist es? Haben Sie Troponien abgenommen?
Ja, schon. Ich habe Geschicht.
Also, verdachte Diagnose wäre auch noch?
Ja, uns anstabiliert angenehmer Pektoris.
Myokartinfarktis?
Genau.
Und, ja, Sie haben ja schon ein paar Untersuchungen gemacht. Was haben Sie schon alles untersucht?
Ich habe schon EKG geschrieben und die Herzinselmen Troponin C, Troponin U, LDH, CK, CKMB überprüft.
Und, ja, Dedimere habe ich auch wegen, vielleicht nun, alte Embolie ausschließen.
Ja, genau. Die haben Sie aber noch nicht ernannt als Differenzialdiagos.
Ja, noch nicht gesagt.
Ja, gut, aber gut, ja, die fehlt uns noch. Richtig, sehr gut.
Gut, was machen Sie jetzt doch mit den Patienten an diagnostischen Maßnahmen?
Ja, wenn er eine ST-Hebung, Myokartinfarktis, muss ich in zwei Stunden, er hat schon zwei Stunden diese Schmerzen, deswegen,
Coronare, Katheter untersuchen muss ich dafür.
Ja. Und haben Sie ihn schon aufgeklärt darüber?
Ja, ich habe geklärt und während dieser Untersuchung werde ich eine, vielleicht ein paar Stanz eingesetzt.
Ah, ja, okay, könnte sein. Ja, okay.
Gut, ja, dann, ja, kümmern Sie sich um den Patienten.
Liegt er schon auf der Intensivstation?
Natürlich, Coronare und Nichts.
Ja, ja, gut.
Dann sollen sich da die anderen Oberärzte kümmern, ich komme aber auch gleich noch dazu. Ja?
Ja, ja, alles klar.
Vielen Dank.
Gut, ja, sprachlich gibt es immer noch einige etliche Probleme.
Ein bisschen, was habe ich korrigiert zwischen drin.
Vom Inhalt denke ich immer, ist alles gut. Ja?
Sie machen eigentlich eine konsequente Abfrage.
Was sein bisschen jetzt war natürlich schwierig, was Sie gut reagiert haben,
dass Sie gesagt haben, wir unterbrechen jetzt und ich muss jetzt erst die Untersuchung machen
und ich gebe Ihnen Sauerstoff und wir legen eine Infusion.
Das war natürlich genau richtig.
Jemanden mit solchen Beschwerden kann man nicht weiter befragen.
Das ist dann immer ein bisschen blöd, die Befragung weiterzuführen,
ja, weil man eigentlich ja schon Befunde hat.
Ja, natürlich, normalerweise, man kann nicht solche Patienten fragen, nur behandeln.
Ja, eben, genau. Ja.
Aber das ist halt irgendwo diese Prüfungssituation und dieser Fallsituation geschuldet
und entsprechend hat der Patient ja auch so ein bisschen ungehalten reagiert,
als Sie dann gefragt haben, nach, was weiß ich, nach Stuhl- und Harm-Problemen
und nach Nyktorie.
Das ist wahrscheinlich im Augenblick wirklich sein geringstes Problem.
Was mich auch gewundert hat, dass Sie sowohl beim Rauchen als auch beim Alkohol gleich gesagt haben,
hey, Sie, da dürfen Sie aber nicht weitermachen, so.
Ich denke mal, das ist in der Situation wahrscheinlich auch nicht das, was der Patient hören will.
Klar, das will keiner irgendwann hören, aber ich glaube, in dieser wirklich Stresssituation
kommt das auch nicht so gut.
Ja, macht absolut.
Nachgang, wenn Sie gefragt werden, ja, wie soll denn der Patient sich weiter verhalten,
dann würde man sicherlich sagen, ja, wir empfehlen natürlich Nikotinabzonenz
und wir empfehlen natürlich Alkoholreduktion, ganz klar.
Ja, aber jetzt in dieser Situation, der war so, ja, wir können Ihnen helfen,
mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören, das ist doch gefährlich, wissen Sie doch.
Ich glaube, das kommt nicht so gut über beim Patienten
und möglicherweise auch bei den Prüfern nicht, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, es ist, was mich ein bisschen...
Sein Vater ist 40 Jahre wegen Myokarte.
Ja, ist natürlich völlig bekloppt, dass der Patient nicht vorher zum Arzt geht, ja.
Er ist schon ein bisschen dumm.
Ja, ich denke, ja.
Ja, und ja, Sie machen tatsächlich immer noch ein bisschen komische sprachliche Flügel ab.
So zum Beispiel, wenn Sie fragen, sind Sie Grippe?
Nee, haben Sie Grippe?
Haben Sie eine Grippe, ja.
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Aber ich habe eine Monat für die Prüfen.
Ja, ich glaube, es ist auch tatsächlich flüssiger geworden von der Sprache.
Aber es sind tatsächlich noch einige Fehler drin.
Aber was mir eigentlich sehr, sehr gut gefallen hat,
wie differenziert Sie gefragt haben, dass Sie zum Beispiel gesagt haben,
ist Ihnen aufgefallen und nicht immer nur dies haben Sie,
sondern natürlich auch gut jetzt, können Sie das einschätzen,
Ihre Schmerzen auf der Schmerzstahler.
Sie haben also sehr schön differenziert gefragt.
Und tatsächlich haben Sie auch so ein bisschen das,
was ja vorher schon gesagt hat, aufgenommen.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, Sie arbeiten als Speditionskaufmann.
Also, dass Sie zugehört haben, was er vorher erzählt hat.
Und dann eben nicht nochmal explizit nachgefragt.
Das fand ich sehr schön.
Und natürlich war das auch für den Patienten angenehm,
dass sie da gesagt, oh, jetzt müssen wir uns aber darum kümmern.
Und ich muss die und die Untersuchung machen.
Wo Sie gemerkt haben, dass Sie nicht gut frei formulieren können.
Das war die Geschichte, also der Nacht gefragt hat,
nach der Herzpartite Untersuchung.
Ja, da waren Sie überrascht
und hatten große Schwierigkeiten, eigentlich das Verfahren zu erklären.
Ja, das war natürlich keine Standardfrage.
Und da müssten Sie aber eigentlich draufgefasst sein,
dass so etwas kommt.
Ja, vielleicht, dass man gerade so eine,
es kommen ja relativ häufig so Herzangelegenheiten
in diesem Notfall an amnesen vor.
Da sollten Sie sich vielleicht noch ein ganz klein bisschen vorbereiten,
dass Sie sich überlegen, wie kann ich das patientengerecht erklären.
Ja, ja, richtig.
Ja, Sie sagen ja, doch, das hat bestimmte Risiken.
Da muss man zum Beispiel sagen, Sie bekommen dazu auch
einen Aufklärungsbogen, den wir zusammen in aller Ruhe durchgehen.
Und da können Sie dann nochmal Ihre Fragen stellen.
Das ist ja tatsächlich so, dass diese Untersuchung
nicht ganz ungefährlich ist,
dass sie aber elementar wichtig ist in dem Augenblick
und möglicherweise lebensrettend sein kann,
wenn gestentet werden muss.
Aber das machen natürlich Spezialkollegen
und die auch mit dem Verfahren routiniert umgehen können.
Auch da muss man dann eben sagen,
unsere Spezialisten sprechen das noch mit ihnen durch
und erklären ihnen das Verfahren noch mal im Einzelnen.
Aber tatsächlich, der Patient hat ja irritiert reagiert,
wie Sie gesagt haben, na ja, wir gehen in die Leistengefäße.
Ich denke, das Herz soll untersucht werden.
Ich habe mich natürlich doof gestellt.
Ja, klar.
Ja, ich weiß von nichts.
Und das ist ja auch schwer begreifbar eigentlich.
Wieso nimmt man ja so einen weiten Weg?
Kann man das nicht einfacher haben?
Ja, gut.
Also auch so etwas müssen Sie aber gefasst sein,
dass Sie irgendwelche blöden Nachfragen
von den Puzzlen aufbekommen sind.
Ja, ja, mit.
Das gehört schon mit dazu.
Was mir aufgefallen ist,
ist, was Sie eigentlich in dieser Anfangsszene
nicht geschildert haben,
dass der Patient vorher solche Beschwerden schon mal hatte
bei Belastung.
Aber jetzt hatte er die Beschwerden ohne Belastung.
Das ist eigentlich auch schon so ein bisschen eine Besonderheit.
Ja, das war ja auch einer der Gründe,
weshalb er gekommen ist.
Ja, einmal weil ihm natürlich auch schlecht war
und weil es so lange gedauert hat.
Aber eben auch, ja, bei Belastung kann das Herz ja schon mal
ein bisschen sich melden.
Ich habe gesagt, aber ich habe früher Belastung,
habe ich abhängig jetzt diese Schmerz.
Ja, aber Sie haben gesagt,
dass er jetzt keine Belastung hatte.
Aber diese, die ich nicht habe, habe ich nicht gesagt.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, dass er das früher bei Belastung hatte.
Ja, aber Sie haben jetzt nicht gesagt,
jetzt war er völlig in Ruhe.
Ja, ich habe gesagt.
Und das war ja für den Patienten irgendwie so die Besonderheit.
Ja, aber ansonsten fand ich,
dass die Situation eigentlich schon auch gut geschildert war.
Auch mit den Nebenwirkungen, wie Kaltspeissigkeit noch sehr.
Dispnell, das haben Sie schön rübergebracht.
Und auch mit den Vorerkrankungen.
Eigentlich hat er ja eine völlig unauffällige vegetative Ananese angegeben.
Die Insomnie, die haben Sie eben so ein bisschen unterstellt,
weil er gesagt hat, ja, wenn ich mal Stress habe,
dann trinke ich halt etwas abends.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das schon als Insomnie bezeichnen kann.
Vielleicht hat er sich auch die Welt nur schön getrunken.
Ja, aber das waren eigentlich diese Sachen.
Und ja, das Vorgehen, das Vorgehen dann in der Notfallsituation war schon richtig.
Und was ich wirklich spannend fand,
bei den Differenzialdiagnosen haben Sie die Exoten wirklich alle mit erwischt.
Dass Sie die Erortensis-Sektion zum Beispiel mit genannt haben.
Das ist ja eigentlich eher eine sehr seltene Diaglose,
aber es ist tatsächlich hier auch mit aufgeführt gewesen.
Sehr schön.
Ja, und die Lungo-Atherian Embry.
Da sind Sie aber über die DDR erst aufgekommen.
Aber Sie haben sie mit genannt dann.
Ja, okay.
Gut.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe mir nur Asche auf mein Haupt zu streuen.
Ich bin total beschämt, dass ich Sie alle so lange habe warten lassen.
Es soll nicht wieder vorkommen.
Danke schön.
Es ist mir wirklich extrem peinlich.
Und wie gesagt, ich hoffe es peinlich wieder.
Und ja, shit happens.
Manchmal passiert einem etwas Blödes.
Entschuldigen Sie bitte alle zusammen.
Ich habe es wirklich nicht absichtlich gemacht.
Ich wünsche Ihnen jetzt trotzdem allen einen schönen Abend, ein gutes Wochenende.